hi I'm Nick Gillespie with my
Declaration of Independence co-author
and reason colleague Matt Welch we're
talking about ask or we're at ask a
libertarian day and the latest question
comes from ATO via our hit-and-run
comments who asks as a libertarian how
do I know that I'm not just a Republican
who wants to smoke pot I will speak for
myself here I don't want to smoke pot
usually because it makes me very
paranoid and giggly and stupid
unproductive but so maybe it doesn't
apply to me I think with how you know
you're a libertarian is that your desire
to have people locked up eight hundred
thousand people a year for smoking pot
is even stronger than your desire not to
smoke it that's kind of an early
indicator and if you just watch for
instance the last presidential debate
when you find for about a half an hour
45 minutes you scratching the wall like
a desperate animal trying to get out of
a cage you're probably a little bit more
libertarian than Republican listening to
people talk about how important it is
that we prevent gay people from marrying
that would prevent Mexicans from coming
to this country and that we engage in
constant war overseas these are some of
the early indicators and also if you
just like the rest of the country are of
an independent bent you're just not
satisfied with what the two major brands
are selling you and you feel like you're
not represented on some basic level by
the the large dominant in groups and
auto I would also ask if you ever want
to get your taxes back our own your own
business and you might also worry that
you're a Democrat who actually has
libertarian leanings as well
you